opah tir du cosmodrome de baïkonour le
drapeau canadien flotte pour la première
fois depuis six ans la fusée soyouz qui
transportera david saint jacques en
orbite est prête pour le grand décompte
il ne manquait plus que la bénédiction
c'est une vieille tradition qui remonte
au premier lancement dans les années 50
même les ingénieurs qui ont assemblé
sont là derrière le prêtre orthodoxe
bénir la fusée fait partie des nombreux
rituels auxquels les russes c'est
absolument la veille du lancement de la
fouillouse les astronautes devront entre
autres se faire couper les cheveux
trinquer à la santé de la mission est
signée la porte de la chambre d'hôtel où
ils sont en quarantaine depuis plus de
deux semaines
puis ils sont apparus pour une dernière
conférence de presse sur terre protégée
jusqu'à la toute fin derrière cet
immense fenêtre devant sa femme et ses
enfants de dessin jack était serein
pendant toutes ces années je le besoin
de lune décevant quand je voudrais que
je devais rester en face de nous
concentrer
je m'en voudrais un ministre
est il plus tôt compris la santé et
d'énergie ce que ça peut sembler mais
récemment il ya eu un dîner de fête me
sente prêt tout et tout est en place et
je ne surprends à vous de jouer comment
ça va vraiment être en anglais il le
sera dans moins de 24 heures il est
confiant même si tout le monde ici pense
aux risques et à l'accident du mois
d'octobre dernier qui a dû ramener la
suisse d'urgence sur terre avec douze
astronautes à bord c'est très excitant
c'est très stressant on est très peu
d'occasions de vol on veut créer
d'autres occasions de vol pour mécaniser
dans l'espace mais dans le cas de david
c'est vraiment david c'est la
quintessence de tout ce qu'on peut
espérer comme compétence scientifique
technique donc fait c'est un de nos
meilleurs ici tout un sacrifice pour une
famille mais tout autant de fierté de
voir un père s'envoler pour une mission
de six mois là ou si peu d'hommes sont
allés jusqu'à mais enfin avoir une
chance de salut de trouver leur voie
il décollera à 6h31 du matin mais pour
eux le décompte est commencé depuis
longtemps ici tamara intéresse coup
radio-canada à baïkonour au kazakhstan